genug knistern der rote gebe zuschauer
denn nun wollen wir markus söder feiern
er ist wenn man zufriedenheitswerte naus
aktuellen umfragen glauben schenken darf
deutschlands unbeliebtester
ministerpräsident
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wo kam respekt herr söder respekt jetzt
mal ehrlich unbeliebtester
ministerpräsident deutschland das ist
nicht einfach bei der harten konkurrenz
muss ich wirklich sagen
wenige wochen vor der landtagswahl steht
söder csu in umfragen bei nur noch 36
prozent weit weg von der absoluten
mehrheit ist unfassbar wie der mann
seine partei geschrumpft hat oder in der
kurzen zeit
dh seine alte strategie selber ein
bisschen afd werden um die afg zu
schwächen geht irgendwie nicht auf also
jedenfalls nicht was die prozente angeht
wäre
während die grünen in bayern zunehmend
nimmt er ab dabei gibt der markus wird
nicht alles im wahlkampf diese woche zum
beispiel beim sogenannten kinos zahlen
wir das kindergeld in deutschland an
unsere kinder aus und beenden wir den
transfer an irgendwelche kriminellen
anderswo in europa meine damen und
herren
da tobt das bierzelt ja weniger geld für
kriminelle
da fällt mir gerade ein stichwort
kriminell und das jetzt keinen spaß weil
er und seine regierung sich weigern
härtere maßnahmen für saubere luft in
münchen durchzusetzen die gerichte
verlangen erwägt die bayerische justiz
erzwingungshaft gegen amtsträger
streicht ihnen das kindergeld wirklich
ja selber vorgeschlagen ich kann auch
populismus wie verzweifelt der mann ist
vor dieser wahl das sieht man am
allerschönsten auf seinen social media
kanälen was er sich da zusammen treated
und instagram das geht auf keine
digitale kuhhaut kategorie eins so da
draussen heute ist sonntag
sonntagnachmittag und ich gehe hier bei
uns in nürnberg im wald spazieren wo ich
bin gerade im allgäu gehe spazieren in
der wunderbaren natur
ich habe den morgen sport gemacht ist
toll
kategorie 2 söder im auto sitze wieder
im auto ist schön wie beim auto
samstagmorgen zum flugzeug an der
unschuldigen dein ego trip mit rein
selbst schuld kategorie 3 söder fummelt
anti atom dann sind das leder wesen und
sie brauchen liebe und zuneigung und
zuwendung ehrlich jetzt auch noch eine
katze alles gut so
er ist aktiv im netz und
jetzt muss man natürlich fairerweise
sagen markus söder ist
selbstverständlich nicht alleine schuld
am niedergang der csu das ist schon eine
teamleistung horst seehofer zum beispiel
auch wahnsinnig mitgeholfen als er
anfang juli um ein haar
sie erinnern sich die groko gesprengt
hätte christian ehring steht im neu
eröffneten haus der bayerischen
geschichte in regensburg gehring ist das
affentheater vom sommer da denn auch
schon thema ja klar die große
sonderausstellung zu ehren seehofers
haust du calypso der erbärmlichsten
putschversuch aller zeiten
zur erinnerung seehofer wollte ja im
sommer tatsächlich die kanzlerin weg
haben
merkel sollte weg er hat noch zum
dobrindt gesagt lasst es wie einen
unfall aussehen weil die uckermärker in
ihm verboten hat flüchtlinge an der
grenze zurückzuweisen
und dann hat er horst einfach mal die
ganz große kanone rausgeholt
ich habe gesagt dass ich beide ämter zur
verfügung stelle dass ich das in den
nächsten drei tagen voll ziel seehofer
droht mit rücktritt
diese video installation zeigt die
reaktion in deutschen
[Applaus]
es war der einzige schöne moment den wir
hatten während dieser scheiß werden
das ist kunst was da gezeigt wird ja ja
ja ja ja ja ja hier
dieses gemälde zb heißt seehofers
masterplan migration
ja ich finde es zeigt die ganze vielfalt
der ideen die horst zu diesem thema hat
die wild sprudelnde kreativität mit der
der künstler
ich weiß auch nicht ja das war wirklich
alles extrem erbärmlich post hofft dass
die union ihm folgt weil alle angst vor
seinem rücktritt haben und an jungs
kalten und sein alter job als
ministerpräsident war da ja schon weg in
die münchner staatskanzlei konnte er
nicht zurück da hatte der so dass schon
die schlösser ausgetauscht also musste
er ganz armselig vom rücktritt
zurücktreten
diese klare übereinkunft die in allen
drei punkten die sie gleich hören werden
meiner vorstellung entspricht erlaubt
mir dass ich das amt des
bundesministeriums des innern für bau
und heimat weiterführen und alles so
hurra damit war das rest vertrauen der
wähler in die groko quasi pulverisiert
auch eine leistung so was haben wir noch
das hier ist die historische bahn
fahrkarte mit der unser innenminister
neulich nicht nach chemnitz gefahren ist
und dieses exponat hier ist was ganz
besonderes das hat tatsächlich angela
merkel gestiftet horst seehofer sah in
formaldehyd geschätzt doch wer trauert
auch noch kaufen
dafür